next up is matthew powers hi matthew
hey how's it going
hey
matthew is a tech
evangelist at cold and he used spark and
pi spark for six years
and now helps devs understand when desk
is a better fit
matthew has written two books he has a
popular blog and regularly contributes
to open source code basis and in the
past life he passed all three cfa exams
and worked in finance and matthew is
going to talk to us about five reasons
parque files are better than csv for
data analysis
uh thank you very much for that
wonderful introduction i appreciate that
all right so let me share my screen
share my screen now let's get to my
presentation
uh can everybody see my screen all right
yes
uh wonderful all right
so
uh excited to start this chat we're
gonna talk about five reasons why
parquet is better than csv
uh i don't really need to introduce
myself after that wonderful introduction
thank you very much
um
so
i uh have a bunch of popular kind of
open source code repository
mainly around
skyline spark
some are python pi spark
a lot of the
helper functions that are covered in
those libraries are kind of cover what
we'll be chatting about in this
presentation here today
here are the
two spark books i wrote one is on
writing beautiful spark code which is
kind of best
practices around structuring a spark
application
and the other is around testing spark
applications which is kind of how you
write functions that are easily testable
and then the benefits of unit testing
your functions
there's just kind of some background
information on myself
enough on that let's dive into the talk
uh
so this is uh what you're going to get
from this talk
so we're going to be chatting uh giving
you some actionable tips on how you can
speed up your analyses
so a lot of data scientists and data
analysts really don't care about file
formats but they love have their
analyses run faster
we're gonna
have a better understanding of
why file formats are so important for
data analyses uh the speedups can be
really significant
um
we'll give you some intuition on how to
choose the right file format for your
particular analyses
i think the intuition is kind of
my most important takeaway i want to
give all the participants in this in
this call today
and this is not going to be a deep
theory talk
more about actual practical advice
so this slide is to kind of motivate why
file formats can matter so much
so
let's suppose you have a lake of csv
files and you're going to be training a
model
and let's suppose it takes eight hours
for your computation to run well that's
actually kind of incredibly painful
whenever you have a computation that's
multi-hours it really impacts how you
you work with the computation
in this case i've had this before where
you kind of
like run the computation and then go to
bed and then hope it worked when you
wake up in the morning and that's that's
really a terrible workflow that you
don't want to have um
sometimes a change
as simple as switching to the parquet
file format from csvs
can give you this kind of 25x
performance improvement that'll get your
model to train in 20 minutes
um
so
let's
look at these
five reasons at a high level before we
dive into them in detail
so
the first reason why park k is better
than csv is because parquet files have
schema info in the file footer
that means you don't need to guess at
the schema or specify it manually it's
way more convenient
another huge advantage of parquet files
is that they're better for compression
so they result in smaller file sizes
which are more performant
parquet is a columnar file format which
means you can just cherry pick
individual columns from the file when
you're reading them into the cluster
which is wonderful from a performance
perspective
similarly
you can cherry pick certain row groups
uh anytime you get that data skipping
that's a huge performance boost
and finally
parquet files are immutable which is a
benefit because
sometimes people will go in there and
sneak and change some stuff around in a
csv file and cause some nasty bugs
so you can't do that with parquet
so the concepts covered in this talk are
applicable to pandas
spark
desk
presto
and other computation engines too so
this is
uh
conceptual we're going to use
das code snippets but the concepts apply
to all these uh different composition
engines
uh okay
let's dive in here
let's look at cluster computations at a
high level kind of how the cluster
interacts with files
so when you run a computation you're
going to want to send data from
files into your cluster to run some
computations that happens in parallel in
a cluster computing system
and the key point to take away from this
slide is
whenever you can send less data to the
cluster you're going to get a really
nice performance gain so just keep that
in mind and let's jump into one of those
ways to send less data to the cluster
and that is called column pruning
so
suppose you have a data set with six
columns of data
and ten rows
now
if you leverage column pruning what you
can do is just grab a subset of the
columns and send those to the cluster
rather than sending all the columns to
the cluster
so as you can imagine if you can send
only a b and c to the cluster for a
given computation rather than a b c d e
f
you're going to get a really nice
performance gain
this is called column pruning and
interestingly enough
this is only available on a column or
file format like parquet so you can't
implement something like this with a row
base file format like csv
so what we're going to do now is
look at a real real world data set
and quantify the performance gains we
can see from column pruning
our
data set is going to look like this it's
going to be
one row of data per second for 20 years
and it's going to have five columns
timestamp id name x and y
and this is the query we're going to run
which is we want to figure out the
number of unique values
in the id column
so pretty simple
so
what we're going to do is run this query
on a csv
data lake and and this data set by the
way is going to have
i think around 615 million rows of data
and we're running these computations on
a five node cluster
so
when we run this computation on
a csv data lake we don't have access to
column printing so we just kind of run
this maybe as you're normally used to
running this this query
and we can see that the result is 367
and this computation takes 2 minutes and
11 seconds to execute
so
not not terrible not great
uh let's take a look at this same query
on a parquet data lake using column
printing
so
here we're taking the same data set uh
on a bunch of parque files
uh we're specifying this columns
argument which is saying hey just grab
the id column don't grab those other
four columns we just care about the id
column because that's the only one
that's relevant for this particular
query
with column pruning we can see that this
query only takes
29.8 seconds to execute and it gives us
the same result
so
what we're seeing here is we're getting
a 4.4 x performance gain for this query
just from using column pruning just
simply from adding this one line of code
which was the columns equal id and using
the parquet file format
so we can already see reason number one
is amazing and gives huge performance
gains
by the way
these data sets are in
public s3 buckets and these notebooks
are in the coiled resources github repo
so if you want to run these computations
on your machine
feel free to go ahead i would love you
to check my benchmarks
okay
off to reason number two uh
of why
parquet is better than csv which is
predicate pushdown filtering
so
with column pruning we saw okay we can
take a subset of the columns and send
those to the cluster
now we're looking how do we take a
subset of the rows and send those to the
cluster
um getting back to our original
principle of any time we can send less
data to the cluster we got a huge
performance benefit
so what we're doing in our baseline
case for a benchmark is we are going to
look at how many rows have an id value
that's greater than
1170
and in this case we're using that same
parquet data set as before
so we can see that
only a small percentage of the data has
an id value that's greater than 1170
and this query takes one minute and 35
seconds to execute
uh cool
let's see how uh how fast we can run
this query if we leverage uh
predicate push down filtering
so in order to leverage predicted push
down filtering we need to supply this
additional argument which are the
filters
and we're saying just give us the id
greater than 1170
and now when we run our query we can see
it can execute in 3.8 seconds and we get
the same result
so
we're querying the same data we're doing
the same exact thing the only difference
is that we've supplied this additional
argument
which is enabling our predicate push
down filtering
so
now we have our beautiful 25x
performance gains
this is what i was alluding to in that
original slide when i was saying hey how
could you take an eight-hour workflow
down to 20 minutes that's what 25x gets
you in this big data space
uh and as you can see this is a total
type of game changer performance
uh let's look at uh
some examples to try to get some
intuition
around
how predicate push down filtering is
working um so you can understand how to
best leverage it in your analyses
so parquet files are separated into row
groups
and what predicate pushdown filtering
does is
based on the filtering criteria it'll
selectively filter out row groups that
don't need to be sent to the cluster at
all
so
when we're running a query and we're
looking for
files
or row groups that have an id
greater than 1070
what parque is going to do is we're
going to look at each of the row groups
and look at the max value in each of the
pro groups and we're only going to grab
a row group that has a max value that's
greater than 1070 because if the id max
value for given row group is not greater
than 1070 we know that it doesn't
contain any data that's relevant for our
query
so in this first row group up here we
can see that the max id value is 946.
so none of that data is relevant for our
query we're looking for ids greater than
1070.
in this second row group we can see the
max id value is 987.
so we can see that
that's not greater than 1070 so
that rare group also does not have any
data that's relevant for our particular
query
now in this third row group we can see
the max id value is 1080
uh so that does have a max value
uh that's greater than 1070. so that
third row group does have data that's
relevant for a query now
one thing to note is
you can't
cherry pick which data in a row group
gets sent to the cluster
you need to send the whole row group
so
the entire row group is sent including
the data that's not relevant so
we need to perform both the predicate
pushdown filtering and it's still going
to give us some data that's irrelevant
and you need to filter that out on the
cluster side
um hopefully that gives you some
intuition around the predicate push down
filtering
which is another extraordinarily
powerful feature of parquet files
uh
okay
continuing on i'm sure you're convinced
already that that parquet is better than
csv so these these
extra reasons are just extraneous at
this point uh but i'll give them to you
anyways
um
so file compression
so
parquet files can be compressed easier
than csv files parquet files are
columnar file format
versus csv files which are robase file
format
so row base files store their data in
this manner on the left
whereas columnar files store their data
similar to the manner on the right it's
kind of like a trend transposed version
of a robase file
now columnar file formats store similar
data next to each other so we can see
like the one two and three are all right
next to each other
uh compression algorithms really like
that
when similar data is near each other
compression algorithms can do their
magic better than they can normally
and that's why
columnar file formats are more
compressible and will result in smaller
file sizes
let's uh look at the recaps of a little
experiment i ran just to confirm this
so what i did was i created a 315
million road data set
and wrote out some gzipped par k files
and then wrote that same exact data set
out as gzip csv files
uh
so i wrote out 521 parquet files and 521
csv files
using the same compression algorithm
just to make sure it's a good
apples-to-apples test
the parquet data was in total
6.3 gigs
and the csv data was 7.5 gigs so the csv
data set was 19 bigger in this case
this shows of course that columnar files
are more suppressable
and this data was written in a public uh
s3 bucket so coiled data sets
time series 1990s
so if you'd like to check this out you
can feel free to query that data
yourself
um
this notebook used to create those data
sets is in the
coiled resources github uh repo if you
want to check it out i'm just gonna show
you the snippet just because this is
cool
this desk data sets uh time series has
been a godsend for me for
experimentation purposes it's such a
nice useful little data set um
so we can see that
uh
we generate this data set it has 315
million rows of data
it has 521 partitions which is the 521
files that get written out
and we're writing those out as part k
files
it looks like there's some q a just
going to take a look um
uh i'm going to take a look at these
questions later
sorry everybody uh
okay
my brain can't handle being distracted
sorry
i will i will answer those questions
though let me try to rush through the
rest of this i'm prepared to answer
those questions
um
okay
so
reason number four why
parquet is better than csv
is that parquet files contain schema
metadata in the file footer
um
okay
so when you're reading a parquet file
there's metadata in the file itself
so the schema in particular is in the
file footer so when you read in the
parquet file you know all of the column
names and all the column types it's just
already there there's no guessing
there's no reason to do inference or
specifying anything so it's just
wonderful
that is not the case with csv files
with csv files you either need to
manually specify the schema
or you need to infer the schema and by
schema i mean the column names and the
column types
manually specifying the schema
is error prone right we don't users
don't necessarily do it correctly
and it can be really tedious uh let's
say your data set has like a thousand
columns who wants to manually specify
that
uh
inferring the schema is equally
unappealing uh you need to either
take a sample of the data and try to
infer it based on the sample
that's quicker but error prone right
you're not necessarily going to infer
properly
or
you need to
infer based on the entire data set which
is expensive that's like a big data
analysis
let's take a look at some of these pain
points
i'm only have 10 minutes left so i need
to rush here
um
so
let's take a look at reading a csv into
a das data frame
so
let's suppose we have this csv data with
first name and age columns
we read it into a dash data frame and we
can see that the d types are correctly
inferred in this case right we didn't
manually specify it so that means that
desk is going to use inference
we can see we've correctly inferred
first name to be an object and the age
to be an integer so in that case we're
sitting pretty
let's look at a case when this doesn't
work out well um
so we have another data set
we have the same first name and age
columns but in this case we have some
messy data in the age
column
now
in this case we're trying to manually
specify the first name should be an
object
the age should be in n64
and this blows up because it's saying
hey we can't cast that weird data into
an n64
so it's correctly blowing up but this is
the types of csv errors that i hate
dealing with
um
so what you might do is say okay well
instead of
manually specifying the schema i'm just
going to infer it and then desk is going
to infer age to be an object which we
don't want because that
it's not an object and that that impacts
the operations we can perform on that
column downstream
so
when you do this with the parquet file
that you don't need to do any inference
you don't need to do any guessing the
schema is already there so we just read
in the the parquet file
uh what desk is going to do is grab the
schema from the footer it's going to
know exactly what the schema is and type
properly type everything
so much more convenient
um
quick pro tip
that's really great when you're working
with parquet files
so pi arrow lets you easily query
the metadata in parquet files
in this little example right here we're
grabbing our parquet file and we're
running the schema method and we can see
that we just can just immediately grab
the skim information for that file it's
incredibly convenient
and
this also ties back with the
parquet predicate pushdown filtering for
the different row groups if you want to
query the
min and max value for each column by
real group that's possible as well
uh
okay
i have eight more
minutes um
last reason why parquet is better than
csv
so
parquet files are immutable
immutability is generally preferable
it's much better to change the code
rather than change the data
i've seen this before folks have a big
csv data lake they try to fix some data
that creates all sorts of weird bugs
can't be undone you really don't want to
change uh data and practice um
in practice if you're dealing with
cloud-based storage this can be a bit of
a moot point because
a csv um that's in an object store like
s3 is immutable in any case
okay
so
i'm hoping at this point you're
convinced that parquet is better than
csv
uh so if you have all these csv files
how do you how do you convert them to
parquet it turns out that's really easy
um
you can just read a bunch of csv files
into a desk data frame and then write
them out as parquet
you can also perform this operation with
spark there's a lot of different
technologies that make this super easy
uh if i am given a csv data lake the
first thing i will do is convert it to
parquet before doing anything else
because
i strongly dislike working with csv
so
the future
what is coming down the pipeline
well
there are additional exciting
technologies that are even improving
upon parquet files
delta lake is an abstraction on top of
parquet that uses
parquet plus a transaction log to add
some additional functionality iceberg is
really another
columnar file store that's really
exciting
i
have given talks previously on delta
lake so feel free to google those if
you're interested in learning more
uh okay
i have a few minutes left for questions
i wanted to leave that
i'm a pretty easy person to get in touch
with
my email address is powers at coil.io
feel free to email me about distributed
computing file formats
desk spark
international travel i love traveling
currently in brazil
uh
i am in the desk slack which is a
wonderful place to be so feel free to
join
i'm also on the desk reddit i actually
created that also created the desk a
linkedin group
so
feel free to ping me in any of those uh
channels i love chatting with the
community
and helping people out so
hopefully you found this presentation
useful and i will take some questions
all right thank you very much matthew
oh parque and csv that's a great topic
and we have many many questions so
let's start with the first one brian
wants to know can you not call him prune
on load of a csv as well though or is
that not possible in desk
it's not that it's not possible on desk
it's just not possible with a robust
file format so
you have to so column pruning is right
like you with csv you have to send all
the data to the cluster and then you can
grab certain columns
with parquet you can just grab some
columns and just cherry pick those and
send them to the cluster and that's the
difference so
anytime so just at a high level there's
certain column there file formats and
row base file formats
um row base file formats are formats
like csv and json and text files
uh columnar file formats are like ocr
and parquet
and column pruning is only possible with
column their file formats
yeah it's a great question
okay and then brian also had a question
when um
they are looking at uh data frame it
passes to pandas read csv which you can
filter use calls to selectively load so
i'm a bit confused about example one
yes
so you can
yeah so use calls
and it's a great question so if you look
at the pandas docs
um because pandas has the same uh same
thing with column pruning and these
limitations so
pandas when you look at the docks like
the reed parkay docks have different
have the column pruning syntax and the
reed csv docks do not have the column
printing syntax so it's the same thing
with pandas
use calls does not use column printing
use calls sends all the data over and
then filters it
okay thank you uh donny has a question
do i have any control over how row
groups are formed when saving a parquet
file
that is a wonderful question um
so
at a like most uh
that's a really great question so
you really want to
sort data
before you write it out if you're going
to want to optimally leverage
um
partition
predicate push down partitioning on that
column value so anytime the data sorted
the row groups are going to be better
organized but like with spark and desk i
don't know of a way to
fine tune it to customize it
so basically the answer is like no but
you can sort
and make it a little bit better but kind
of know
just so you know this is a related
topic
so data bricks has two versions of delta
one is the open source delta lake one is
the closed source delta delta lake
closed source delta lake has something
called z order indexing which is kind of
like the customized way of doing this
but that's the proprietary databricks
way so
look at google databricks z order
indexing if you want to get into like
the all the messy details with that one
all right well thank you
let's take a couple more questions we
have like one minute left maybe one
question more alan wants to know can a
schema have things like engineering
units or valid ranges and not just types
yes it can
maybe not the schema but you can add
custom metadata to
parquet files i actually wrote a blog
post on that so
i think if you google something like
pierrot custom metadata
you can
find that so i don't know if that could
be in the schema itself but i know you
can add it to the
you know you can add arbitrary data
to the parquet footer
and great questions good good audience i
couldn't see anybody so i'm just talking
to the void over here but you all exist
you had great questions so thank you
maybe you know you can see each other a
little bit on gather town or on the
slack
where you can continue this conversation
thank you so much matthew and thanks for
being a part of pi data global 2021.
you're very welcome thanks for hosting
you